allô allô allô allô sim commissaire oui
c'est encore moi vous avez reconnu ma
voix bah oui je sais je vous téléphone
souvent je vous importune mais je suis
tellement utile à monsieur commissaire
ya plus d'un an maintenant que ma
fiancée a disparu et vous n'avez rien de
trouver un
même pas un petit morceau oui je sais
que je suis macabre avec ce que vous
voulez dans des moments pareils on pense
au pire et c'était une femme qui
cherchait à se mettre en quatre pour
faire plaisir ça pue donné l'idée à
quelqu'un
et oui je sais je n'aimerais pas penser
à ça mais vous comprenez je le devais en
faire ma moitié
enfin je veux dire on devait se marier
juste avant de disparaître
il m'a donné une procuration sur tous
ses biens alors mettez vous à ma place
je ne sais pas comment la remercier et
moi qu'est ce que je vais faire de tout
cet argent maintenant oui bien sûr des
dons oui bien sûr monsieur le
commissaire des dons aux oeuvres de la
police oui oui bien sûr j'y pensais mais
enfin vous n'avez vraiment rien trouvé
vous avez cherché partout même pas
j'suis pas moins un petit temps de
cendres mais oui je lèverai pas penser à
ça mais ça arrive sur commissaire je
vous jure safari
ah bon vous vous pensez qu'elle est
partie avec un homme rond dans le fond
ça me rassure un peu parce que la
dernière fois qu'on l'a vu elle prenait
le train c'est ça oui avec un homme
qu'on n'a pas pu identifier
pradines lot
on vraiment n'a pas pu l'identifier oui
c'est votre conclusion vous arrêtez
l'anc est là dessus oui écoutez je suis
désolé monsieur le commissaire je n'ai
plus qu'à vous dire merci et adieu à
tubes succès chery bonne nouvelle on va
pouvoir se marier
ouais t'es content pas tu vas enfin
appeler madame londres ru